[Applause]
thank you and wow wasn't that entrance
incredible
and isn't this an amazing venue really
it's just remarkable
and welcome to the all-star city of
henderson and thank you to all of our
all-star guests let's give them all a
hand
first i'd like to acknowledge my fellow
council members from ward 1 councilwoman
michelle romero
ward 2 mayor pro tem dan shaw
ward 3 councilman mars who unfortunately
is out of town and not able to join us
today
ward 4 councilman dan stewart
and i thank each of you for your
collaboration and friendship these past
two years have presented so many
challenges and i'm grateful for our
strong relationship and the united
mindset that we share in serving the
good of our community
and i know that we're all keeping the
people of ukraine in our hearts today
and praying for their safety
and the safety of the men and women of
america's armed forces who've been
deployed to bolster our nato alliance
and who are service and who are serving
at home and abroad in defense of our
nation
and welcome to the other elected
officials who are with us today and all
of the special guests who have joined us
as well
and i'd like to welcome my family and
friends who have joined me today
especially my granddaughter ayla
and my son former army ranger and silver
star recipient david price who traveled
all the way from idaho to be with us
today
and i also want to acknowledge our city
manager and ceo richard derrick we're so
lucky to have the benefit of his
leadership and it hasn't gone unnoticed
he's been named to the list of the 10
most dynamic ceos of 2021 by excel on
and was recently recognized with the
southwest alliance
2021 leadership award let's give it up
for our all-star richard derek
i also want to recognize his executive
team deputy city manager bristol
ellington
assistant city managers stephanie
garcia-vos and rob herr
and welcome to the dollar loan center
also known as house henderson the new
home of the henderson silver night
[Music]
and how cool is it that this is the
first event in this spectacular
community events center
and we're thrilled with our partnership
with the golden knights organization it
started with lifeguard arena on water
street and led to a joint effort to
create this incredible venue
thank you bill foley
carrie bubols and chuck brennan for
making this possible for us to have this
event here today thank you very much
[Applause]
and we're grateful to the knights
organization and the las vegas raiders
for helping to sponsor this year's state
of the city thank you very much as well
thank you
and how about the dlc staff supporting
us today it's their very first event
here and they've done a remarkable job
haven't they
let's give them a hand
i want to congratulate our public works
team as well ed mcguire
lance olson troy westover jennifer
johnson and the entire team under chief
infrastructure officer rob hurst
leadership to all of you a job well done
some might say it was risky to proceed
with the construction during the
pandemic when there were so many
unknowns yet we remained focused on our
strategic priorities and knew that this
investment would elevate our
entertainment offerings create new
economic opportunities for us and build
a community gathering place
so when others around were stopping
projects we gave the green light and in
doing so we saved the city about 40
million dollars compared to other
construction projects that uh
waited instead of moving ahead so let's
boast a bit here
not only was the center completed in 18
months but we did it for about 50
dollars less per square foot than
comparable projects across the country
look around you that's just really
remarkable to see a facility like this
built in 18 months
and even on an accelerated schedule this
building will receive not one
but two green globe awards now that's an
achievement
we hope that you'll take advantage of
kerry's invitation to walk around and
check out this world-class facility at
the end of the program
this event center opens a whole new
world of entertainment options from
concerts and symphony performances to
community gatherings like graduations to
events on the outdoor plaza and so much
more
we built this for you henderson what do
you think
so four years ago there were no
professional sports teams in henderson
and today we get to cheer on our
hometown teams the henderson silver
knights
the raiders our lady aces and the
nighthawks whose very first season
begins right here later this month
we're also excited to welcome the big
west basketball championship next week
which will bring an estimated 13 million
dollars of economic impact to our city
henderson is well positioned to host
major sporting events like these in the
future
we've got a fantastic arena great
henderson hotels and restaurants and
easy access to airports and an amazing
community support and this is just the
beginning
so for me it sure feels good to show off
this henderson jersey and we have much
more to cheer about it's time to
celebrate just how far we've come
in 1942 this area first became known as
henderson it's amazing to think about
all that's happened in the 80 years
since our basic beginnings
when henderson was incorporated in 1953
we had a population of 7 400 people
we could almost fit the entire town
right here in this arena
now that's now that we have more than
330 000 residents who choose henderson
to call their place to call home a
tagline that we adopted more than 25
years ago today we get to mark another
important milestone in our history
you may have noticed our new logo
the centerpiece of the city's new brand
identity
and i'm proud to share it with you today
during the last few decades
we've seen unparalleled expansion
major corporations national franchises
and professional sports teams all
calling henderson home
there comes a time when a city's brand
needs to be more versatile more
recognizable and more modern and that
time is now
it was our vision to ensure that our
brand evolved aligning with the bright
prospects on the horizon
all henderson services events and
programs are now instantaneously
recognizable as coming from a single
premier organization
and by transitioning our old logo into
our city seal we will continue to honor
our small town roots and preserve the
pioneering spirit of old henderson
isn't it amazing to consider just how
far we've come since those industrial
days
our city was initially formed on just 13
square miles today we span more than 118
square miles
henderson is nevada's second largest
city
and think about it we're now larger than
st louis
cincinnati and pittsburgh in fact we're
now one of the top 100 big cities in
america
and just as in those early days when
president kennedy declared henderson a
city of destiny we continue to be among
the fastest growing cities in the united
states
we've seen a population increase
by more than 30 percent since the 2010
census
and yet we still offer the same hometown
feel that makes living learning working
and playing here so special
and none of this happened by accident
henderson has a long history of
visionary leadership and today we remain
focused on our strategic priorities
at a recent henderson historical society
event i shared the stage with the three
mayors who preceded me mayors grosbeck
gibson and hafen
together the four of us spanned almost
30 years of our city's history
it was fun to share our stories and our
perspectives and we acknowledged that
each of us stood on the shoulders of the
mayors who came before us
the potential for what this community
could and would become was in the minds
of our early leaders long ago and every
mayor and council since has stayed true
to that vision building upon the
cornerstone of a great city
today we continue to see the results of
plans that were first initiated years
ago
we remain committed to what makes
henderson great while also navigating
new challenges and breaking new ground
in fact we literally broke ground last
month in our new center of excellence
which will be a game changer for all of
us
while staying true to our plans we've
also remained flexible and nimble to
grab hold of new opportunities when they
appear
we're here at the dlc because a previous
mayor and council envisioned a community
focused venue and made it part of their
plan that of course was the henderson
pavilion which became a favorite
gathering place for residents and
visitors alike
then unexpected damage to the pavilion
presented the exciting opportunity to
take it to the next level
and i think you'll agree this facility
is indeed the next level
so more than a decade ago we endeavored
to pass the the
and secure passage of the omnibus public
lands management act which conveyed more
than 500 acres of federal land to the
southern nevada limited transition area
we saw huge results from that investment
of time and effort
welcoming haas automation
a high-tech industrial park and other
companies now changing the landscape of
our city
today we're supporting the southern
nevada economic development and
conservation act sponsored by senator
catherine cortez masto
this new lands bill could make
additional federal lands available for
economic development
residential neighborhoods and land
conservation efforts
every decision that we make is for the
benefit of our community and our
taxpayers because we know that we're
setting the foundation for generations
to come
all of this comes with a steadfast
commitment to our goal of being
america's premier community and i want
to share some of the progress that we've
made in our key strategic priorities
first is our focus on community safety
our community survey consistently ranks
rakes
rates public safety is one of the top
issues for residents and we're proud to
be ranked second safest large city in
america once again
and that's because henderson continues
to significantly invest in public safety
to maintain a strong fire and police
departments
with almost 60 percent of our operating
budget dedicated to keeping our
community safe the henderson police
department embraced a new mission this
year
excellence in safety and service and
they deliver on that promise every day
we added 31 new police and corrections
officers to the force last year and
trained new bicycle officers
11 community and neighborhood resource
officers are now assigned to specific
geographic areas to support neighborhood
watch groups homeless outreach and more
and we recently broke ground on hpd's
new west substation that will house a
state of the art communications center
and the hpd academy
it will open this fall as the fourth
substation in henderson and the first to
be added in 15 years
henderson's crime lab is one of only
three accredited public-funded forensic
laboratories in nevada providing
multi-jurisdictional support with
evidence analysis
we received bond approval to build a
brand new state-of-the-art crime lab and
evidence vault to keep them at the
forefront of innovation for the region
and i'd like to acknowledge anthony
zeiker creator of the acclaimed tv
series csi for his generous donation to
our community foundation
which will help to develop this crime
lab
and maybe it's time for a series reboot
what do you think csi henderson does
that sound like a hit
i'm proud that we've added three new
fire stations since i took office in
2017 including the newest station at
cadence which will begin safeguarding
our community this fall
our fire department continues to be in
the top
0.5 percent in the nation and let me
repeat that top 0.5
percent in the nation
and the team was recently recognized
with the american heart association's
mission lifeline goal plus achievement
award for the third year in a row
i commend fire chief sean white and
police chief frederick anders for their
leadership and i want to recognize the
exemplary men and women of the henderson
police and fire departments thank you
i must also acknowledge the continued
covet response by our public safety
departments
in our opening we recognize some of our
city's first responders and healthcare
heroes let's give another hand to them
for all that they do and have done
during the past two years
i also want to call out our dedicated
emergency management team who's
overseeing the ever changing and ever
challenging pandemic response for the
last 24 months
and the community development and
services team whose coveted response
plan became a model for the management
of the pandemic throughout the region
and received national american planning
association awards for that plan
they also received a state apa award
recognizing our outreach to vulnerable
population
thanks to these efforts henderson has
received or has achieved the highest
vaccination rate in nevada more than 80
percent of our eligible residents have
received at least one dose
thank you
that alone has had a huge impact on our
economic recovery which leads us to our
second priority
we have a lot to celebrate with our
community's economic vitality
it's wonderful to see so many of our
local businesses taking part in our
celebration today and fun to include so
many mascots in our opening procession
our thanks goes to president scott
mulrath with the henderson chamber of
commerce for all that they do to support
our business community thank you scott
as we continue our economic recovery i'm
pleased to report that in 2021
our development services center
processed a near record-setting volume
of twenty thousand permits it's
remarkable
as you've seen development and growth
are happening all over the city and i'll
share just a few highlights with you
vodatech will be completing their 50
million dollar remodel of the former
sears building on warm springs road
expanding their operations as a world
leader in the design and manufacture of
embedded computing solutions
barclays is in the process of doubling
their financial service workforce to
more than two thousand employees in
their henderson location over the next
18 months
in fast growing west henderson advanced
manufacturing leader haas automation is
grading its site and is expected to
start vertical construction early next
year
amazon's second facility is open so you
can thank henderson for all those little
grade delivery vans bringing those
packages to your doors
and we're excited to see the progress on
henderson west a 102 acre development
that will offer almost three thousand
residential units
this will include a wide variety of
medium and high density housing types
that are not commonly found in southern
nevada expanding housing options in our
community
kenno health plans to add two new
facilities in henderson to improve the
health outcomes for our seniors
henderson hospital at union village
opened their second tower and is
celebrating their fourth year with a
designation of a leapfrog top hospital
the valley health
hospital system will be building its
second facility west henderson hospital
at saint rose and raiders way
it will be built in three phases
ultimately providing
a six-story half million dollar half
million square foot hospital tower with
three medical offices
and an emergency heliport for flight for
life
and this spring dignity health saint
rose dominican hospital will begin
celebrating their 75th year in henderson
in 1947 a train arrived carrying seven
nuns here to take over the war hospital
today there are still none serving in a
variety of roles at saint rose de lima
and siena campuses and we're pleased to
recognize the adrian dominican sisters
who are here with us today
including sister katie who attended the
same high school i did immaculata high
school in detroit thank you sisters
thank you
investment in our redevelopment areas is
also going strong
our historic down in our historic
downtown we celebrated the grand opening
of the new water street plaza just
outside city hall
the plaza's reimagined plan received a
state apa award for outstanding plan
implementation successfully transforming
this area into a premier entertainment
destination where culture and commerce
converge
more than 30 years ago we envisioned
having a hotel on water street someday
and that day is now
the new owners of past casino have
submitted plans to make that vision a
modern reality directly across from
lifeguard arena
after a multi-million dollar remodel
last year including the new circus
sports book the six story well at the
pass will soon be our very first hotel
on water street we're very excited about
that
[Applause]
across the street the 55 million
watermark mixed use project will open by
the end of summer
it will offer 155 luxury apartments
plus retail and office space and will be
the tallest building in downtown
henderson
south end on water street is another
mixed use development with which is a
seven million dollar investment
that will be completed later this year
this pioneer project for downtown
henderson includes office retail and
residential uses and even includes a
bocce ball court at the new azura
italian cucina
another project modis development will
finish construction of 50 new
multi-family residential units by the
end of this year
the city's redevelopment agency has
helped to coordinate investments of more
than six million dollars into small
businesses in the water street district
these efforts have resulted in almost
300 new jobs in downtown henderson
in december cadence marked their seventh
anniversary
they now have surpassed 4 500 homes and
we recently celebrated the grand opening
of the new smith's marketplace
progress on the 152-acre union village
also continues
a second wolf apartment complex is
completed and new medical and dental
offices have opened
and a master plan is in development for
the lake moore canyon redevelopment area
as a result of these efforts and a sign
of just how far we've come since the
great recession the redevelopment agency
set aside almost three million dollars
in 2021 for our public schools
quality education is another strategic
priority area where we've made great
progress
how about the performance of the
foothill high schools marching band
weren't they amazing
and how fun to have so many of our
school mascots join us today as well
i'd like to acknowledge principal
solomon and the students representing
our national blue ribbon school lamping
elementary who are here with us today
and we're excited to see hannah brown
elementary school open this year just
down the road and i think hannah brown
is here or was here she just made it
there she is thank you hannah the
namesake of the school thank you for
being here
and we broke ground on the new coral
academy in cadence
and waller yes
[Applause]
while our community survey again showed
strong support for creating smaller
school districts we continue to support
ccsd through education set aside funding
and partnerships since 2015 we've
invested more than nine million dollars
to bring additional resources to
henderson's teachers and students
in partnership with google we created
the one hill resilience project to
provide teachers and school
administrators with hands-on tools and
training to foster social emotional
learning
and this is exciting
we have a new usda farm to school grant
which will allocate 88 thousand dollars
to create hydroponic garden systems at
four henderson elementary schools in
coordination with green our planet
we also partner with the ccsd
to create the career career
opportunities for students like camp 911
which showcases firefighter and police
officer skills to middle school students
we look forward to the development of a
new ccsd career and technical academy in
2024 as well
this school will prepare students for
advanced manufacturing and other skilled
jobs so that they can find career
opportunities right here in our
community
in higher education nevada state college
just marked its 20 20th anniversary and
is one of the fastest growing colleges
in the nation
nsc's new president dr pollard has a
dynamic vision and is setting the course
for their continued evolution dr pollard
the new glenn and andy christensen
school of education at nsc opened last
year and will significantly increase our
teacher pipeline
the college of southern nevada recently
celebrated their 50th anniversary under
the leadership of dr zaragoza
both schools are incredible partners to
the city of henderson and are helping to
solve the workforce needs of our
community thank you dr zaragoza
the betty inglestad school of health
sciences a partnership between nsc and
csn will help to address critical needs
of our community for more health care
professionals and we're partnering with
csn to build a new center of excellence
right next to haas automation
this training center will prepare our
current and future workforce for the
high skilled jobs in henderson
needless to say all of these projects
will draw even more companies to
relocate and to expand here
henderson boasts our own highly skilled
team that continues to deliver on our
next strategic priority high performing
public services
for the second year in a row the review
journal and the business press have
recognized henderson
as one of nevada's top workplaces for
2021
and we achieve that while maintaining
one of the leanest governments with only
6.7 employees per thousand residents
i want to commend our chief financial
officer jim mcintosh and his team for
their stewardship jim
the city manages over a half a billion
dollar budget prudently and efficiently
even amidst a global pandemic we've
maintained our double a plus bond rating
and that's significant
and in henderson property taxes are just
77 cents per hundred dollars of assessed
value while other large municipalities
in nevada are closer to a dollar or more
the finance team also manages more than
130 million dollars in grant awards last
year i've already commended our public
works department for their oversight of
the dlc
but they also have hundreds of projects
in various stages of design and
construction including millions in
infrastructure investment
close to 40 million dollars was spent on
road and flood control improvements last
year which included ndot and rtc funded
projects
plans are underway to modernize the
henderson spaghetti bowl where all of
our highways converge
the team is also hard at work
maintaining our roads and making
improvements to ease congestion and to
keep traffic moving
they also manage the annexation process
of eight thousand acres of land in el
dorado valley into the city's limits
and out of 35 000 vehicle fleets in
america henderson is ranked in the top
100.
our public works and utility departments
are the only two agencies in southern
nevada accredited by the american public
works association
our commitment to public service
includes a focus on sustainability which
is one of my top priorities
our sustainability program was launched
in 2009 when i first joined the city
council
sustainability considerations are
integrated into the way that we do
business and we continually improve the
efficiency of city operations
henderson was significant henderson has
significantly reduced our energy
consumption and lowered emissions
through the integration of renewable
energy sources and a variety of energy
efficiency initiatives
our focus on sustainability has resulted
in a continued reduction
of henderson's contribution to climate
change and less air pollution locally
of course we're also focused on water
conservation in 1922 the colorado river
compact was established and our
percentage of water rights hasn't
changed in 100 years
because of our conservation efforts over
the last 20 years we've been able to
grow without substantially increasing
our water consumption
as we face ongoing drought we're focused
on reducing wasteful outdoor use by
ensuring compliance with watering
restrictions and removing non-functional
turf
on city property
yeah
we're also increasing rates for mega
users to encourage them to scale back
it's a privilege to lead a city that's
committed to the standards that will
sustain our premier community for
generations to come
[Applause]
the quality of life that we offer
henderson residents is truly remarkable
and that's because of our commitment to
the final strategic priority
livable communities
we continue to invest in our mature
neighborhoods to keep them as vital and
welcoming as when they were first built
back in 1978 green valley was the first
master planned community in southern
nevada and it set the standard for today
we've developed a number of
master-planned communities since then
including lake las vegas tuscany village
and anthem
today cadence is one of the top
performing master planned communities in
the nation and inspirada is not far
behind
and part of what makes our quality of
life so special is our goal to provide a
park or a park amenity within a
10-minute walk of every resident
at tessa park opened this year and we
just broke ground on montana park which
will be the sixth park in inspirada
and henderson's 69th park will soon open
at union village
i mentioned earlier that henderson
started on just 13 square miles
today we offer more than 220 miles of
hiking and biking trails
after a 15-year effort our harry reid
union pacific railroad trail is now
complete
it will be opening soon
this five mile trail connects pecos road
to acacia park with access to boulder
city via the river mountain loop trail
and thanks to the work of senator
richard bryan and harry reid to complete
the southern nevada public lands
management act henderson recently
recently received more than 14 million
dollars for three more parks and trail
projects in our community
our parks and recreation department has
won the national gold medal twice and
was recently reaccredited for their the
20th year
along with the best parks henderson is
ranked in the top 20 best cities for
veterans to live and we continue to
focus on our veterans programs
we honor our veterans throughout the
year and in 2021 we welcomed a new
veterans organization forum to enhance
communications and collaboration with
the groups who serve our heroes
henderson is a place for everyone to
call home and we strive to enhance the
quality of life for all of our residents
we were so proud to receive a perfect
score on the human rights campaign 2021
municipal equality index which measures
support for the lgbtq plus community
members who live and work in our city
we're also proactive in our efforts to
provide assistance to those experiencing
homelessness in henderson and sensitive
to the residents concerns about the
growth of the homeless population in our
community
we facilitated the distribution of
nearly three million dollars to help
residents in need last year including
increased housing options and
revitalization of existing neighborhoods
as part of our coven 19 response we
received 1.1 million dollars in
emergency solutions grants to implement
homeless assistance programs
and we partnered with the unlv school of
social work on a survey to help us to
better understand the needs of those
experiencing homelessness and the
barriers to the resources
as i survey how each of the city's
strategic areas are coming to fruition
i can barely contain the pride that i
feel
and it's not just personal pride but
deep pride in the incredible city of
henderson team that i've had the
pleasure to work with for almost 20
years since i first joined the henderson
planning commission
it's true that teamwork makes the dream
work and we truly do have a dream team
here at the city of henderson
yes
these are some of the most talented
professionals that i've ever seen
as our community continues to grow and
to evolve regardless of the challenges
that may lay ahead we will stay focused
on our vision
i like to say have a plan and work that
plan the city's vision is to be
america's premier community but how will
we know that we've made it
we'll know by assessing our processes
and results against national best
practices
the bloomberg what works cities is a
national certification organization that
uses best practice standards in order to
assess municipal organizations as to how
they improve outcomes
in january we participated in a
bloomberg philanthropy site visit and
assessment i'm very excited that we will
know shortly if we've achieved what the
what works city certification a
recognition that only a few dozen cities
across the country have achieved
another way that the city is charting a
course on its path to premiere is by
using the baldrige approach and feedback
to improve the way that we do was do
business the malcolm baldrige national
quality award criteria is the standard
for improving organizational performance
and guess what
since beginning our baldrige journey in
2012 henderson's been recognized with
two pioneer awards and two category
awards for best practices and innovative
approaches
that's a big deal
last august the city was assessed on 250
standards for performance excellence
using the baldrige criteria and we're
waiting word later this month to see if
we will receive the pinnacle award the
top rating from the southwest alliance
for excellence so keep your fingers
crossed right
whether or not we receive this award
this year we know that we're hitting the
mark because our residents and business
community have told us so
in a statistically valid 2021 community
survey henderson residents told us that
they love our city
even in the midst of a pandemic
henderson continues to re to receive
very high marks consistent with past
surveys going all the way back to twenty
ten
ninety seven percent of those who gave
us their opinion expressed satisfaction
with henderson's quality of life and 94
said that they were satisfied with the
quality of services provided by the city
and we scored 20 points higher than the
average for cities in the mountain
region on satisfaction as a place to
live a place to raise a family and a
place to retire
henderson also scored more than 35
points higher than the average for
cities across the u.s for value received
for city tax dollars and fees including
high satisfaction for our police
services
and quality of our parks and recreation
programs
for the first time we also completed a
separate business community survey in
2021
and the results were very very
encouraging
among those business owners are
operators who shared their opinions 95
percent said that the city of henderson
is business friendly and nearly 90
percent rated the city
as an excellent or good place to do
business and i hope that you'll all
agree
our all-star team of city staff also got
high marks for their professionalism and
competency as did our business
assistance program and infrastructure
and public safety services and we earned
high marks for quality of life at 93
percent and quality of services at
nearly 90 percent both 20 percent higher
than the national average and that's
pretty awesome
we're encouraged by the positive
feedback we continue to receive from the
residents and businesses who call
henderson proud home i'm so proud that
we've accompli what we've accomplished
together and i'm sharing the secrets
with my colleagues here today beyond my
service as your mayor
i've had the opportunity to share my
expertise in planning to expand our
influence across the region
ten years ago henderson spearheaded
southern nevada strong the first
federally recognized regional plan and
believe me that is a really big deal
our team secured the grant funding and i
had the privilege of leading the most
extensive and inclusive planning effort
ever undertaken in southern nevada
that effort generated grants and other
funds that have benefited all of our
jurisdictions
southern nevada strong will continue to
guide collaborative efforts to plan
create and to sustain
quality development in this region for
years to come and its impact will be
felt for generations to come
i'm also privileged to be the first
woman and first mayor to serve as the
chair of the regional flood control
district and the regional transportation
commission of southern nevada
[Applause]
my role gives henderson a greater voice
in the decisions about flood control
roadways and public transit and
transportation planning in the region
u.s department of transportation
secretary pete buttigieg
visited henderson last year to award us
an infra grant of nearly 40 million
dollars those funds will kick-start the
boulder highway reimagined project which
is one of the department of
transportation's top national priorities
this funding will help to implement the
city's vision for boulder highway by
enhancing automobile bicycle and
pedestrian safety and improving the area
this project will also be a catalyst for
the redevelopment of the corridor with a
total investment of 130 million dollars
through 2024 and our leadership on this
project will be a showcase for the
region on how to design and build
transit for the future let's have
transit on boulder highway
[Applause]
i've lived in nevada for more than 40
years
and i've poured my heart and soul into
this community a community that i love
we truly have so much to celebrate and
yet none of these accomplishments would
have been possible without all of you
our twelfth man
or woman
or for our knights fans our seventh
player
while you may not be on the ice or on
the 10-yard line you're still an
essential extension of our team you are
our supporters and our greatest fans
cheering us on
showing up on game day and rooting for
our success
the work that our team does every day is
with you in mind
ensuring that henderson remains a
premier community depends on all of us
we've worked hard to get where we are
today
and we're intent on building a
foundation for the future through smart
strategic growth
this may be my last season in this
jersey with the city of henderson but
we've got the right team in place
we've got a winning strategy we're
focused on our rebounds and we're
scoring like nobody's business and i'm
confident that henderson has an
unbeatable all-star future ahead
we have much to celebrate and even more
to look forward to together
we're achieving the vision to be
america's premier community so let's
cheer for our all-star city go henderson
go
go hendersonville
go henderson
go
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much